haha the Joe Rogan experience you commit
to letting someone use something on you
yeah you know commit to a small what to
put a vibrator in your taint okay hey
hey hey it's not real let's just hang
out yeah use a tarragon on my taint
right let's just talk yeah you don't
have to do that there was who was this
girl in college and she's the chain
smoke and drink tab all day
it was everything everything about it
was just kind of manufactured and mmm
you know she's perfect just perfect and
I remember one time like I was over her
house and I we kind of broken up and
she'd had a party and she's like hey why
don't you stick around it's like nah man
I'm gonna head out
she's like no stay stay I was like NAT
she's like I have toys I'm like alright
let's crack another beer and she took
you over the top that's because I never
played with toys and and she opened up
her her bottom drawer her dresser and it
was like a [ __ ] hardware store all
the sizes and shapes and uh do you
remember post 9/11 when Stanhope would
travel with a suitcase filled with
dildos no yes that was his thing that
was his thing Stanhope would travel with
a whole suitcase filled with dildos
that's great like a shoe salesman let me
show you my wares I mean they're a
hundred percent legal they have yeah so
he would just get checked and every TSA
anybody what in the [ __ ] and they'd open
up his bags just dicks rubber dicks but
what kind of girl do you go bet you go
back to his hotel room and he opens up
his suitcase and you're you just start
using those same kind of girl that loves
tan oh yeah yeah that's right
perfect perfect yeah yeah you know it's
uh he just wipes it down with his tie
just good old honest advertising now
listen I see that you like me and you've
come back to my room can I assume I can
put in hardware that's been in other
women and
side of you right now yes sure let's do
it let's smoke cigarettes - yeah let's
take some mushroom smoke a cigarette
[ __ ] yeah let's make some phone calls -
filthy dildos inside of me every time I
get a phone call from Stanhope it's it's
like oh yeah I hope he's drunk what do
you got what are you doing oh yeah right
now we got into yoga for a while now not
yoga biking and hiking hell yeah I did
so yeah he no he did yoga - yeah he met
this lady down in Tucson he was writing
a book and she's she was a cyclist right
um anyway she got him like to stop
drinking for a while start eating
healthy start exercising start riding a
bike and she was like getting him to do
it on a regular basis huh yeah I was
like what how is this possible
I don't know if he maintained I was
assumed it was just a cleansing period
for weed hot back yeah I think that on
the booze that makes being a drunk could
get boring if he never took a break you
got to step away once in a while clean
it up and then feel the joy of going
back down into the darkness
[Applause]